[Music]
sarah sanders
great courage today joined the view and
some of the co-hosts they didn't want to
hear any of it when sarah spoke
about the mob violence democratic-run
cities for decades the president's
accomplishments
too much for joyless to handle take a
look
the worst places we have these problems
are where democrats have been allowed to
lead
we're finally starting to clean this
mess up starting to make things better
this is a president who has empowered
the african-american community
he's done more than his predecessors we
have the lowest unemployment for black
americans
historic funding for hbcus opportunity
zones
criminal justice
here now the author of the brand new
book just out today it is speaking for
myself
faith freedom and the fight of our lives
inside the trump white house former
white house press secretary fox news
contributor sarah sanders
i don't know how you did your job as
press secretary i don't know how spicer
did it i don't know how kayleigh
mack and he does it couldn't pay me all
the money in the world to do that job
but then you take it to the view
really a lot of courage there
i definitely like coming on your show a
lot better sean
that's for sure and uh they didn't like
it very much when i
reminded them as they were talking about
the problems in all these major cities
who was the one that was leading those
major cities it was very interesting
that the second i started naming off all
of the accomplishments
and all of the things that the president
has done to empower
the black community and help the black
community they quickly cut me off and
decided it was time
to move on let's not forget that one of
the hosts of that show
actually called the president a
terrorist despite the fact that
four years this president i i i might
have probably missed
joyless oh joyless behar yeah
yes despite the fact that the president
spent the last four years wiping the
most
dangerous terrorists off the face of the
planet they
are the definition of hypocrisy and
they've decided that they
hate this president more than they love
this country
and it has never been more evident than
the fact that they can't
be happy about the positive things that
this president has done
to help all americans particularly black
americans across this country
you know i i look at the enthusiasm in
north carolina tonight
and i don't see that for joe biden i
look at the accomplishments
they can't acknowledge a single thing
donald trump has done well
because biden and obama they didn't set
record low on employment they didn't do
opportunity zones
joe's record on race they left
after eight years with 13 million more
americans on food stamps
8 million more in poverty the lowest
labor participation rate
since the 70s and then the iranian
mueller deal
150 billion i don't think that's a good
record to run on sarah
not at all and if you don't believe me
just listen to joe biden's running mate
during the primary she actually pointed
out how bad joe biden's record was
when it came to race relations during
his almost
five decades in public service he has
done
nothing in almost 50 years to help black
americans why should we expect him to do
that now
the contrast is clear and donald trump
needs to be reelected in november
you bring us inside the white house and
the real donald trump i read the book
cover to cover this weekend
well done sarah sanders
amazon.comhannity.com bookstores
everywhere